the I sense worm is an international
public think tank that was founded in
nineteen ninety-three for two reasons
Germany had just been reunified and
there was a concern that a wave of
nationalism might take place under
reunification and there was also a
concern from a different direction that
the West would culturally overtake and
colonize the East which in many ways did
happen so some people in the
intellectual political community of
Berlin and Brandenburg which is the
state surrounding Berlin decided to
found an institute in the name of
Einstein who had his summer home there
it's actually the world's only Einstein
house that was built by Einstein and
still cold designed by Einstein and in
the name of Einstein who was not simply
a one of the great physicists of all
times but a major public intellectual
who was right on virtually all political
issues of his time to found an institute
in his name to further intellectual
exchange outside the university Einstein
had this marvelous house to which he
didn't escape he simply invited the
world to come to him he invited some of
the best thinkers and politicians and
artists of his time to just hang out in
an informal way and talk about
everything and anything and that's what
we did